[Music]
hey would it be possible to use
uh the lagrange point to make a giant
pile of space debris
seems like that would be easier than
bringing it all back to earth
and much more ethical than just flinging
it out into space
also in the future we could use it like
an auto junk yard
and when we want components or metals or
stuff like that
we could just go to that to build in
space instead of recycling oh
wow that's right so so maura but tell us
first about lagrange points
yeah so basically these are points in
a three-body system where uh
you have some stable and some unstable
points places where
uh this gravitational influence in in
that system
is let's let's say kind of null things
cancel each other out
um but yeah out of the five out of the
five points
out of the five lagrange points i
believe two of them
are are stable and the other three are
unstable and so
i would say this we need to find ways of
not creating orbital landfills
so so the thing is sending stuff to
lagrange point
uh while you might be able and oh by the
way even when you send stuff there it
doesn't mean
it just stays there forever like you
know eventually the thing's gonna drift
out just due to
perturbations that are non-gravitational
uh mostly and that sort of stuff plus
as as neil you you clearly you know this
uh there's more than just
a few bodies in in in the universe and
so eventually
uh you know the curvature of space-time
will force these things out
uh if they're uncontrolled so it's not a
good answer
and uh uh it's not a viable solution and
we should avoid
uh trying to find the place in space to
just send garbage to
right so uh yeah and so basically
let me just see if i got this right he's
asking whether or not we could create
a celestial equivalent
of our ocean's great garbage patch
which is where the currents come
together and create a stillness
and then let's do that in space and
let's do this do that in space
i love so we don't want we don't want to
do that okay so just
let me throw some astrophysics in here
okay the one of the legrands one of the
attractive
lagrange points in the jupiter orbit
the jupiter sun orbit there's a leading
lagrange point and a trailing lagrange
point
if you look there there are asteroids
that have
collected there and they're called the
trojan asteroids
and so it's it's fascinating and we knew
to look there because we said
here's a place where all the
gravitational forces cancel out
so there's got to be some anything that
sort of drifts in won't have a reason to
drift out
very quickly or at all so we actually
find these places that have our
repositories but i'd like the trash heap
example and i think a samford and sun
space in space we should do that
for sure when if we do do that
it should have the theme song that goes
on
without doubt yeah we
and by the way every time you drop
something off
in that great uh junkyard in the sky
you should hear shut up dummy
all right give me give me some more all
right here we go
chris newbury and chris says
uh hey chuck bet you don't get my last
name correct on the first try oh
man all right that and that
see i should read these first uh i'm
going to say new bry
instead of newbury but anyway because
it's uh any wbry
dr tyson just love you and uh love uh
your cosmic queries book um spacex
the idea that put 42 000 satellites into
orbit for optimal internet around the
world
that being said does that put a lot of
junk
into orbit how much does that increase
the risk
of future endeavors uh of this
rock having such a net
surrounding it oh so
let me reshape that slightly so more
about if we have functioning satellites
then they're not junk but if you have
thousands and thousands of functioning
satellites isn't there still a risk that
they could collide with each other
yes and and so and so i would say this
low earth orbit is already
building itself up to be this place with
these functioning satellites like you
said owned by different companies
but there isn't uh a space traffic
coordination
uh entity right so so the thing is
people are making decisions about how to
maneuver and go you know how they want
their satellites to behave
but they're doing that in the absence of
coordinating with other people that are
also making decisions and so that does
increase the risk of things uh you know
bumping into each other in the night so
to speak
and it's not and space isn't just so
supremely empty that we shouldn't worry
about it
no because we have very specific orbital
highways where we put these
satellites given the purpose that we
want and right now for instance
uh you know with spacex and the
starlinks which oh by the way
you know out of the nearly 30 000
objects that we track
about 3 500 are working satellites and
elon owns about you know 1500 of those
so so it's already quite a bit but uh
wait so wait chuck
elon is going to become skynet oh my god
oh
yes look at that and skynet's going to
be
achieve consciousness right and then
throw the robots
off and by the way neil he's your friend
okay i do count him as a friend that's
true
[Laughter]
you say that like okay i'm also to blame
just because i know the guy
yeah all right well i thought hold on a
second so i'm not saying that that
elon is at fault for anything what i'm
what i am saying is that he owns
most of the working uh satellites uh in
earth orbit
he will continue to own most of them um
as i see now given
the fact that he's got licenses to
launch
and so pretty much if you want to go
beyond 500 kilometer altitude you've got
to coordinate with elon
because because you got to go through
his layer of starling satellites so
the coordination piece is really
important and
that has not uh become manifest yet so
that is an issue
so i got this elon is the next james
bond so he's double 08.
and they say uh i've
licensed to launch right
right salons license to launch exactly
that's the next thing
oh my god well first of all that sounds
ominous
right right because uh that guy may be
on his way to being the uh the first
uh real super villain
and you heard how quickly morbid back
pedal
on on pulling out his name let me say
something nice about
it before you go to the next topic
i didn't mean he's bad no no no he's
good there's nothing wrong with elon
yeah we all know that jeff bezos is
really the bad one
yeah he's the villain plus he's bald
like like
um you know what he he actually does
make for the perfect
looks like yeah he's going to be the
world's first trillionaire
probably because he'll be the one that
will land on an asteroid and mine it and
it's present yeah
[Music]